usual suspects the guys on top  are the usual suspects yeah already the  top guys are getting to to the top  so  i don't know what he's doing now  this looks pretty  anti-positional  i guess now  i helped him a little bit maybe  maybe i helped him a lot  yeah um  so we have someone requesting the mad  landline  who is requesting that one  yeah it's some anonymous person in chat  the mad lads uh requesting them that's  gonna suck a pawn to get the double do  you know the madeline line yes yes  let's see if we can get it in the mad  landline is one of the  it's not  it's not really a greek or a bone clad  opening but it's related it's like in  the barn club family  i'd say extended family yeah  okay now i'm obviously winning this game  oh i had queen g6 on my last move as  well so many mates good  so